tué en France une fusion et des adieux
Christian Blanc quitte la présidence
d'airfance et d'Air Inter c'est le
premier titre de notre résumé en imag
préparé commenté par Christophe Bardi
Air Inter c'est fini la compagnie a en
effet fusionné cet après-midi avec sa
grande sœur Air France pour ne plus
former qu'un seul groupe c'est aussi la
fin du règne de Christian Blanc le PDG
souhaitait que le nouveau groupe Air
France soit privatisé Lionel Jospin en
ayant décidé autrement Christian Blanc a
annoncé qu'il n'irait pas au terme de
son mandat qui expirait normalement le 7
octobre à quelques jours de son départ
donc le PDG d'Air France n'a pas caché
son émotion de voir fusionner les deux
compagnies il y a à la fois un peu de
nostalgie lorsqu'une entreprise qui a eu
l'identité d' inter très forte se fond
dans un nouvel ensemble mais en même
temps c'est c'est un acte de naissance
c'est c'est c'est c'est
l'avenir